digamos que quiere encontrar el volumen
de un cubo en donde los valores de este
cubo son x es mayor o igual a 0 y menor
o igual a 3
lleva a ser mayor o igual a 0 y menor o
igual a 4
y aceptan va a ser mayor o igual a 0 y
menor o igual que 2
yo sé que si ustedes han visto geometría
básica pueden calcular el volumen de
este cubo multiplicando la profundidad
por la altura por lo largo pero quiero
hacer este ejemplo para que ustedes se
acostumbren a ver cómo luce una integral
triple
ahora vamos a dibujar este volumen vamos
a dibujar un eje este es mi eje
y eje de mi eje z y mi eje x aquí voy a
poner las letras
este es el eje x y y ceta
así que x va a estar entre 0 y 3
así que vamos a dibujar los más o menos
por acá 1 2 3
y es de 0 a 4
así que el x está un poquito por acá
esta es como que la base de nuestro cubo
z está entre 0 y 2 así que tenemos 12
aquí sería la parte superior del cubo
y lo vamos a dejar en otro color
diferente para que se note mejor estoy
de más o menos para acá en el eje x
y desde a por acá
el límite está aquí aquí está la otra
cara y unimos esta última
así que queremos calcular el volumen de
este cubo sabemos que la profundidad es
el ancho es de 4 así que 3 por 4 12
estar es de 12 y lo multiplicamos por la
altura que la altura es 2 entonces 2 por
2 24 podemos decir que el volumen es de
24 unidades cúbicas pero ahora vamos a
hacerla como una integral triple como lo
hacemos lo que podemos hacer es tomar el
volumen de una porción muy pequeña
no quiero decir área porque será un poco
contradictorio así que digamos que
quiero encontrar el volumen de un cubo
muy pequeño eso lo vamos a encontrar más
útil cuando comencemos a ver límites
variables y áreas y superficies como
límites pero digamos que queremos
calcular el volumen de este pequeño
cubito de aquí
este es mi pequeño cubo que es más
pequeño que este cubo rectángulo o como
lo quieran ver cuál es el volumen de
este como vamos a decir que su ancho es
de de esta porción es de su altura es de
x bueno nos de hecho se los estoy
diciendo al revés la altura es en el eje
z así que esta parte será de x y la
altura es de z así que podemos decir que
el volumen de este pequeño cubo
que le llamamos dv
o que es el volumen diferencial va a ser
igual o el ancho por el alto por la
profundidad de x de jay-z
el orden no importa ya saben que la
multiplicación puede darse en cualquier
orden
pero qué es lo que podemos hacer con
esto aquí bueno podemos tomar la
integral todo lo que las integrales nos
ayudan es a realizar sumas infinitas de
entre pequeñas distancias como esta de
zeta de x o de ella así que lo que
podemos hacer es tomar este cubo
y primero hacer la sumatoria digamos que
en la dirección de zeta
tomamos el cubo y lo agregamos en el eje
de arriba hacia abajo
para poder obtener el volumen de esta
columna y como se va a ver esto como
vamos a tomar la suma en la dirección de
zeta
vamos a tener una integral digamos cuál
es el valor más chico de nuestro eje z
cuando z es igual a 0 y el valor
superior vamos a llegar hasta el valor
de 2 hasta que z es igual a 2
y por supuesto se va a tomar la suma
estas vez
primero de zeta
qué es la integral con respecto a z y
después vamos a hacer la integral con
respecto ayer y por último la integral
con respecto a x así que esta integral
este valor como lo he escrito aquí nos
va a dar el valor de una columna dado
son unas x 10 ya que esto es una función
de x siguiente pero estamos trabajando
con todas las constantes aquí así que va
a ser un valor constante del volumen de
una de estas columnas que esencialmente
será dos veces de x porque la altura de
una de estas columnas es 2 y su ancho y
profundidad es de x de ella y ahora
podemos tomar esas columnas y moverlas
en la dirección x bien para hacer las
sumas del volumen total para hacer la
suma de la dirección xy hacemos otra
integral similar a esto
pero ahora en la dirección
y la dirección y el rango de lleva de 0
hasta 4 así que bueno aunque sea un
poquito medio extraña está integral aquí
hasta la izquierda desde que ya es igual
a 0 hasta que ya es igual a 4 y esto nos
da el volumen de una hoja que es
paralela al plano detalle y ahora lo
único que nos resta hacer es agregar
varias de estas hojas en la dirección x
para poder ahora sí tener el volumen de
nuestra figura total así que agregamos a
estas hojas con otra integral en la
dirección x desde x igual a cero hasta x
igual a 3 y para evaluar esto pues es
algo bastante directo primero vamos a
realizar la integral con respecto a z
como aquí no tenemos nada escrito en
esta parte así que podemos asumir que
esto es un 1 ya que esto es lo mismo que
deserta por d por de x que uno por de
por de z por de x así que cuál es el
valor de esta integral bueno la anti
derivada de 1 con respecto a z es zeta
así que esta es eta y esto lo vamos a
evaluar desde 2 a 0
y nos queda
2 - 0 nos queda 2 la integral de 2 desde
que es igual a cero hasta que ella es
igual a 4 de ella
y tenemos la integral mx desde x 0 a x
igual a 3 de x y noten cuando integramos
con respecto a z terminamos con una
integral doble esta integral doble es
exactamente la misma que hubiéramos
hecho en los vídeos anteriores cuando
hablábamos de integrales dobles en donde
decíamos que z estaba en función de x y
z es una función de x y xi y que es
igual a 2 es una función constante
independiente de xy pero si definimos z
de esta manera tenemos que encontrar el
volumen bajo esta superficie donde la
superficie de zeta es igual a 2 ésta es
la superficie de zeta igualados y
terminamos con esto como ven lo que
hacemos con las integrales triples no es
en absoluto diferente y ustedes se
pueden preguntar bueno para que las
estamos haciendo entonces y se los
mostré en un momento aquí vamos a tomar
la anti derivada con respecto ayer y nos
va a quedar 2 a ver permiten bajar un
poquito para tener más espacio
2 evaluada de 0 a 4 nos queda 2008 - 0
nos queda 8 con la integral de 0 a 3 de
x esto va a ser 8 x x evaluado en 0 y en
3 8 por 3 24 así que serán 24 unidades
cúbicas sé que aquí la pregunta más
obvia es para qué nos sirve esto bueno
cuando se tienen valores constantes
simplemente se pudo haber hecho una
integral doble pero qué tal si yo les
hubiera dicho que nuestro objetivo no
era calcular el volumen sino la masa de
este objeto y aún más
que la masa de este esta área o de este
espacio de volumen no es uniforme la
masa de aquí no este uniforme no estaba
uniformemente distribuida si fuera
uniformes podríamos simplemente
multiplicar su densidad uniforme por su
volumen para obtener la más pero digamos
que la densidad también puede ser nos el
volumen de algún gas o algún material
con diferentes compuestos en él así que
digamos que de su densidad es una
función variable de x y z
entonces la densidad que es esta letra
row
que parece una p pero es la letra que
normalmente se usa en la física para
expresar densidad es una función de xy
de iu y de zeta
y vamos a hacerlo simple vamos a decir
que es igual a equis por james por zeta
si quisiéramos calcular la masa de
cualquier volumen pequeño sería ese
volumen multiplicado por la densidad
porque las unidades de densidad
kilogramos por metro cúbico si
multiplicamos esto por un metro cúbico
nos queda kilogramos así que podemos
decir que la masa voy a escribir aquí en
notación de masa
bueno mejor eso no es una función mejor
lo escribo de otra manera
y la diferencial de la masa de una masa
muy pequeña va a ser igual a la densidad
en ese punto x etc
multiplicado por el volumen de esa
pequeña masa y ese volumen ese pequeño
volumen lo podemos escribir como de ve y
nosotros sabemos que debe es igual a
decir que es el ancho por el alto por la
profundidad este volumen no siempre
tiene que ser x por 10 por zetas podrían
ser otras coordenadas como las
coordenadas polares o algo ligeramente
diferente y eso lo haremos eventualmente
pero si queremos calcular la masa usando
estas coordenadas sería la función de
densidad en ese punto x nuestra
diferencial de volumen x de x de jay-z
así que cuando quieren calcular el
volumen o más bien calcular la masa que
sólo haremos en un vídeo posterior
esencialmente vamos a tener que integrar
esto esta función en oposición a lo que
hicimos ahorita con el 1 integrado en z
y x eso lo haremos en el siguiente vídeo
y verán que simplemente se trata de
hacer anti derivadas sencillas y evitar
cometer pequeños errores
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo